I hope you're entertained I hope you're
moved and I hope you just loved it like
I did I want you to feel like this can
still be your home
I love the season so much Thanks and one
of the things I think that fans are
going to freak out about is dad hopper I
know he's full dad mode like I never
thought I'd be Bob Saget in full house
watching you go red in the face so many
times how are you approaching this new
layer of dad hopper mic at one point
calls it a fat tomato which is a really
lovely thing for handsome young man like
him to say how many children are you
friends with so in the first season he
really had like a different thing like
he had a ruggedness and kind of a
toughness to him you know going into
season two he's sort of opening himself
up and he's becoming a little softer in
a certain way so season three like you
know he can't pop the to Anne dolls
anymore and he can't really smoke as
many cigarettes or drink as much as he
used to so he's got to do something with
all that weird anger and rage so it's
he's decided it's chips and salsa like
in front of the TV like copious amounts
and the occasional like Snickers bar not
the occasional the very many circus bar
I measure you know he's getting bigger
and he's also getting a little softer
and in his demeanor and but he still got
that beating heroic heart of Jim Hoppa
that we've known and loved but it's
great to see him change and to see how
he's growing I really like the fact that
the duffer's are letting him go through
I can fight
I need you safe when you read the finale
script for season three what was your
initial reaction I thought it was
stunning I mean I don't know how these
guys can outdo themselves because I
remember thinking season 1 was so
extraordinary soon dude was over here
and then I was like you'll never be able
to have the payoffs that you had
especially the season 1 payoff but then
even that season to pay off with closing
the gate you'll never be able to do it
and they did it like tenfold I mean I've
never been so impressed with the script
there's not a lagging moment the entire
I think it's an hour in 10 minutes the
last episode it's a long episode and
there's not a moment where I'm I wasn't
glued and like yelling at the characters
on the screen you when I watch it all
put together even though I know what's
gonna happen I sit there and I cry and I
laugh and I go like no don't do that
what are you doing like so it's like to
get that response out of me like these
guys are just brilliant brilliant
writers brilliant directors and I'm just
it is such an honor to work on this show
really well lastly what's your message
to the fans after they've watched it
what do you want to say to them as
they're reaching for their tissues it's
all gonna be okay no it's like um I
don't know I mean I hope you're
entertained I hope you're moved and I
hope you just loved it like I did and it
is you know it's been a true honor it's
true what they're saying
every day that's gonna lose you
[Music]